Havana you just uh made a draw in the
game with Shakira media but I first of
all I was wondering how much time did
you spend to check in social media
yesterday after that game you know and
Dr Marcus withdrew from the tournament
actually I I spent quite a lot of time
because it is a very interesting thing I
mean
we haven't had any like really major
scandals in the Chess World and this is
first one in quite a while
I mean it's
maybe like the biggest chess Scandal
since uh The Chronic whole match of 2006
so it's been a while
um so yeah I was really really quite a
bit of what people are saying yeah you
bothered this tweet like you want more
so it was not enough no but this was
just a joke because uh you know Magnus
had his podcast with one episode called
the Magnus effect and uh I was one like
I thought that this podcast was
basically just
to announce
um like or to talk about his uh why he's
not defending his title in the world
championship and so now he has something
else that is quite it's quite juicy to
talk about uh so I was wondering okay
just just a bit of a play on words and a
bit of a joke yeah absolutely and what
kind of effect because on your situation
in the tournament and grantchester right
now suddenly you check the standings and
probably uh found yourself sharing the
second place before this game no but I'm
not really sure I mean like hands as
possible because uh
like his winning his Magnus doesn't
count and it only shows that like we're
tied because he got let's say a zero for
that game right because the game wasn't
played and I'll get a zero in the last
round when I was supposed to play Magnus
so uh so I'm still half a point uh
behind behind him behind Wesley and
behind yeah who okay Jan is clearly the
biggest beneficiary in the terms of the
tournament for this because uh he lost
the game and this game is as an adult so
he went from 50 to possibleness actually
um for me it doesn't change much I mean
and if anything it's not not really good
for my tournament because it was you
know I already had an extra black in the
tournament
and now I have two extra blocks because
my last round white against Magnus is
erased
um but I I don't like look at it as you
know personally as a negative or
positive it's uh
uh I mean for the Chess World it's a
negative of course but
for my tournaments it doesn't change so
much yeah what about today's game how
did it go for you
oh well the game was very interesting
um
but I guess it's not a surprise to say
that this is kind of a forced line it's
drawn uh it's not a new idea level and
Rooney played this queen E7 very rare
move
and it clearly took a sharp Mirror by
surprise he played a very dubious Bishop
to D3
well I shouldn't say do because it's
it's a fine move I mean at least to a
draw but basically what is white is
walking a tightrope after that destroy
you have to find his Queen G1 and all
this stuff uh but then he calculated it
brilliantly he found all the correct
moves and it was it was a draw
um
so yeah I was surprised by his decision
that it's super risky to play Bishop D3
I mean white could also be amazing you
know his King is on E2 and he's not even
on material but uh but the way we played
was all very correct and the four-strom
yeah I saw you were talking after the
game did he explain some of his
decisions
well no he just
um asked me more or less if the game was
correct because it's clear that he was
uh played on his own and I I came with
preparation
um so he just asked me and I told him
that Queen G1 and everything that he
found was correct and he said that this
queen G1 idea was uh took him some while
to proceed because uh
it's it's a bit strange the queen
usually doesn't defend the king via G1
uh so he said that
um that it took him some while to see
that detail that he's okay here
and uh
but how did it feel actually to play
today in the play the song without
Magnus without alireza who was supposed
to play against him today
well I mean it was more yesterday when
it came as a surprise today it's uh
you know we already knew what was what
was happening but yesterday I kind of
heard that some something would happen
before the game like I I just heard some
rumor that there would be some sort of
you know some development and and I
didn't really think so much of it and
then
and then it happened I mean yeah I saw
that Magnuson shop but he forfeited the
game
and uh but today already we you know
we're used to the situation
and uh
yeah I mean we'll see what happens of
course because uh it's quite
quite a big thing to withdraw from the
tournament I don't know if Magnus has
done it before
during the tournament I'm sure he's you
know withdrawn before his ornaments but
during the tournament it's quite a big
development exactly thank you so much
and we are waiting for more news
hopefully okay
[Music]
thank you Anastasia and just an example
leader of the type of content that
people can enjoy on our social media
channel so be sure to subscribe in the